고전적 최적화는 고전-양자 혼합 알고리즘에서 핵심적인 단계야
변분 양자 고유값 분해기나 양자 머신러닝 같은 거 말이야.
근데 고차원 파라미터 공간에서
복잡한 함수를 최소화하는 게 쉽지 않다는 게 밝혀졌어.
안녕, 나는 Victoria Lipinska야. 이 영상에서 우리는
고전-양자 혼합 알고리즘을 위한 고전적 최적화 루틴을 살펴볼 거야.
최적화 문제는 쉽지 않아.
파라미터 수가 늘어나면, 가능한 값의 조합 수도 늘어나는데
그게 지수적으로 증가해.
체스를 예로 들면, 64개의 칸이 있고
각 플레이어는 말이 16개야. 각 플레이어가 말 하나를 움직이고 나면
400가지 다른 포지션이 나와. 두 번 움직이면 72,084가지 포지션,
세 번이면 약 900만 가지, 그리고 약
2,800억 가지가 네 번 움직였을 때 나와.
40번만 움직여도 가능한 포지션 수는
10의 120승 정도로 추정돼.
완벽한 게임을 하려면 가능한 모든 포지션을 탐색해야 하는데
이 엄청난 성장세 때문에 모든 포지션을
하나하나 다 검토하는 건 불가능해.
이 문제는 두 개의 더 작은 부분 문제로 나눠서 해결할 수 있어.
먼저, 게임의 미래 단계에서
나타날 가능성이 높은 체스판 상태를 파악해야 해.
이걸 관심 부분 공간이라고 부를게.
그리고 두 번째로, 그 부분 공간이 주어졌을 때 최선의 수가 무엇인지 결정해야 해.
이걸 최선의 수라고 부를게.
이 비유에서 관심 부분 공간을 처음 탐색하는 과정이
고전적 최적화 알고리즘의 역할과 같아.
그 관심 부분 공간이 파악되고 나면,
보통 양자 알고리즘이 최선의 수를 찾는 역할을 맡아,
그 부분 공간이 주어진 상태에서 말이야.
파라미터 하나만 고려하는 것부터 시작해 보자,
theta, 우리가 최적화하고 싶은 비용 함수를 매개변수화하는 거야.
함수를 플롯하면 이렇게 생겼다고 해 보자,
X축에는 파라미터 theta의 값이 있고
Y축에는 비용 함수가 있어.
비용 함수는 실제 금전적 비용일 수도 있다는 걸 명심해
최소화하려는 거, 또는 변분 양자 고유값 분해기에서 자주 그렇듯이
자연이 최소화하는 에너지일 수도 있어.
우리의 목표는 가장 낮은 비용에
해당하는 theta를 찾는 거야.
theta의 초기값에서 시작해서 매 최적화 단계마다
비용을 더 줄이는 새로운 theta를 찾아.
그래프를 볼 수 있다면 어느 방향으로 가야 할지 꽤 쉽게 알 것 같지?
근데 최적화의 어려움은 실제로는 그걸 모른다는 거야.
선택한 theta에서 함수를 평가했을 때 비용만 알 수 있거든,
전체 퍼즐의 아주 작은 조각만 알게 되는 셈이야.
이게 최적화가 일반적으로 작동하는 방식이야.
최적화기는 파라미터 theta를 샘플링하고 비용을 계산해.
상상할 수 있듯이, 파라미터 theta를 무작위로 선택해서 함수의 전체적인
위상을 재구성하는 건 그다지 효율적이지 않아.
대신, 스마트한 최적화기가 하는 건 각 단계에서
함수의 그래디언트를 찾는 거야.
이렇게 하면 최적화기가 플롯에서 어느 방향으로
가야 가장 낮은 비용을 찾는지 알 수 있어.
그래디언트가 0이 되면 알고리즘이 종료되고,
최솟값을 찾은 거야.
이 최솟값은 전역 최솟값이 아닐 수도 있어.
지역 최솟값일 수도 있거든,
근방에서 비용 함수의 가장 작은 값이기는 하지만
전체 theta 범위에서 가장 작은 건 아닐 수도 있어.
파라미터가 하나인 경우에는 분명히 그럴 수 있어.
근데 파라미터가 많아질수록,
함수는 더 복잡해져.
파라미터가 두 개만 돼도 이미 곡면이 되고,
네 개가 되면 더 이상 그릴 수도 없어.
체스 예시처럼, 모든 가능성을 재현하는 건
금방 다루기 힘들어져.
고차원 파라미터 공간에서
복잡한 함수를 최소화하기가 어렵다는 걸 알 수 있어.
근데 합리적인 결과를 얻으려면 고전적 최적화
루틴이 빠르면서도 정확해야 해.
또한 노이즈에 강인해야 하는데,
근시일 내 양자 컴퓨터에서 이게 상당한 영향을 미칠 거야.
고전적 최적화 알고리즘은 크게 두 가지로 나눌 수 있어
직접 탐색법과 그래디언트 기반 방법 두 가지로.
그래디언트 기반 방법은 최적화 과정 중에
함수의 그래디언트 정보가 필요해.
이건 해석적으로 계산하거나
유한 차분 계산으로 근사할 수 있어.
직접 탐색법은 그래디언트 정보를 사용하지 않고
다른 전략을 써서 비용 함수를 최소화해.
양자 컴퓨팅 분야에서 가장 많이 쓰이는
최적화 알고리즘은 다음과 같아.
COBYLA는 선형 근사에 의한 제약 최적화를 뜻하고
그래디언트가 필요 없는 최적화 알고리즘이야.
SLSQP는 순차 최소 제곱 프로그래밍이고,
그래디언트 기반 최적화 알고리즘이야.
확률적 섭동 벡터를 사용해서
비용 함수의 근사 그래디언트를 동시에 계산해.
노이즈가 없는 환경에서는 COBYLA 같은 최적화기들이
SPSA보다 더 빠르게 수렴하는 것으로 밝혀졌어.
고전적 최적화기는 자체적인 파라미터가 있어
특정 경우에 맞게 지정할 수 있는데, 예를 들면 스텝 크기 같은 거야.
이런 건 보통 특정 최적화기와 관련된
문서에서 찾을 수 있어.
최신 고전적 최적화기 비교를 위해 아래 참고 문헌 목록을
확인해 보길 권해.
파라미터화된 quantum circuit의 고전적 최적화와 관련된
또 하나의 현상을 살펴보자.
앞서 봤듯이, 비용 함수의 그래디언트가 소멸하면 최적화기가 흥미로운 특징이 없는
평탄한 고원에 갇혔다는 걸 나타낼 수 있는데, 이른바
"barren plateau"야.
barren plateau는 여러 요인의 결과일 수 있어.
무작위로 초기화된 파라미터를 가진 quantum circuit에 해당하는
비용 함수의 그래디언트는
qubit 수에 따라 지수적으로 0에 가까워져.
최적화기가 탐색하는 양자 공간이
qubit 수가 늘어날수록 지수적으로 커지기 때문이야.
이 문제를 해결하는 방법으로는 파라미터 수를 줄이는 것,
즉 기반 공간의 차원을 줄이는 것도 있어.
barren plateau 문제의 원인을 다른 방식으로 생각해 보면
지수적으로 큰 파라미터 공간을 마주한 파라미터화된 circuit의
문제에 무관한 특성 때문일 수도 있어.
고려하는 문제에 맞게 circuit을 설계하는 것이
좋은 해결책이 될 수 있어.
barren plateau를 유발하는 지수적 파라미터 공간 외에도,
다른 물리적 현상들도 이를 발생시킬 수 있어:
양자 컴퓨팅 실험에 존재하는 노이즈와 디코히런스,
파라미터화된 circuit의 전반적인 표현력,
또는 모델링된 비용 함수의 비국소성과 얽힘 정도 같은 것들이야.
이 과제들을 해결하는 건 여전히 활발한 연구 분야야.
이제 VQE의 주요 구성 요소를 살펴봤으니,
다음 영상에서 알고리즘을 요약해 볼게.